it's another day in trump's america and
therefore
another one of these just horrifying
dystopian
authoritarian incidents uh to tell you
about
donald trump has fired the head of cyber
security for the department of homeland
security
why because the head of former head of
cyber security
said there was no widespread voter fraud
directly implying joe biden really did
win
donald trump really did lose we call
this reality we
call this the facts we call this re
living in the real world but
unfortunately
doesn't work if you work for donald
trump i'm talking about
christopher krebs the director of the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency this is part of the
department of homeland security
he reportedly expected to be fired
consider that for a second this
president's capricious nature and
complete intolerance to what are to him
inconvenient truths it's so widely known
that his head of cyber security expected
to be fired
for saying the results are real
joe biden really won there was no
widespread voter fraud he
anticipated that saying that
would get him fired and the sequence
here was that krebs
agency put out a statement saying
we've looked at all of the allegations
and we find no evidence of voter fraud
in the 2020 election and the statement
included a section that said quote
the november third election was the most
secure in american history
right now across the country election
officials are
reviewing and double checking the entire
election process prior to finalizing the
result
when states have close elections many
will recount ballots all
of these states with close results in
the 2020 presidential race
have paper records of each vote allowing
the ability to go back and count each
ballot
if necessary this is an added benefit
for security and resilience
this process allows for the
identification
and correction of any mistakes or errors
there is no evidence that any voting
system
deleted or lost votes changed
votes or was in any way compromised
of course trump's entire case that
he won is based on all sorts of claims
of exactly what christopher krebs said
there is no evidence of fraud observers
being blocked
votes flipping votes being deleted via
voting machine manipulation
it's the full gamut that trump has
alleged and it's the full gamut that
christopher krebs
said uh it didn't happen christopher
krebs putting out a statement saying
none of those things happened and donald
trump fires him
donald trump then tweeted about this
firing saying quote the recent statement
by kris krebs on the security of the
2020 election
was highly inaccurate in that there were
massive improprieties and fraud
including dead people voting that's been
debunked poll watchers not allowed into
polling locations
there were republican and democratic
poll watchers everywhere
glitches in the voting machines which
changed votes from trump to biden no
evidence of that late voting and many
more no evidence of late voting of
course
as long as you vote by election day
votes can be counted as they arrive
after the fact
and then he goes on to say therefore
effective immediately kris krebs
has been terminated as director of the
cyber security
and infrastructure security agency
there is no evidence of any of the
things donald trump is alleging these
are the things that donald trump and his
cronies have been claiming
but courts and election officers have so
far not found merit to these claims
and indeed these tweets were flagged by
twitter
as being disputed claims about election
fraud
it's starting to seem like disputed
might not be a strong enough flag
for twitter i mean the things that
donald trump is tweeting
there's no evidence for them it's it's
not merely disputed it's like if
i said humans actually breathe helium
not oxygen and it pops up this is a
disputed claim about science well it's
more than disputed it's completely vapid
there's no evidence for it whatsoever
but in any case twitter flags aside
after being fired kris krebs tweeted
simply
honored to serve we did it right
defend today secure tomorrow
at this point is being fired by trump
simply for doing your job a sort of
badge of honor because
you know we've been talking about so
many of these hangers on
around donald trump who have done his
lying and his bidding and his
disinformation uh spreading they really
deserve to never work again
kaylee mcinanny is an example we'll talk
about her later people like corey
lewandowski
um you know steve bannon these are
people who if we had a
fair world where actions had
fair consequences they would never work
again now i'm not calling for anybody to
starve
they should all have enough to eat hell
they should even have health care
but what i'm saying is that their
malfeasance
is so severe that they should be
unemployable by any moral right-thinking
employer okay
on the uh they probably will all get
great consulting gigs or media gigs or
who knows what
on the other hand you have people who
simply are doing their job like for
example
kris krebs is in charge of analyzing
whether the election
took place in a secure fashion or
whether there was the widespread fraud
that has been alleged
he did his job he looked at it there's
no it's not even being asserted that
kris krebs was politically
influenced or strong-armed by someone or
part of some conspiracy to falsely give
the election to ju
it's not even being alleged in any
serious way maybe some on the internet
are alleging that but it's it's not even
an allegation he simply did his job and
this is the conclusion he came to
and he was fired he was just you're
fired that's it you're just gone
um is that now i mean have we fallen so
far
that that that is now a badge of honor
or some kind
uh these are bizarre times that we are
living in and hopefully at a certain
point
we will get back to a status quo that
makes a little bit more sense
right now it really doesn't and it's
horrifying our uh i don't want to say
our current allies because some of them
are distanced at this point because of
the trump presidency
but our historical allies are regularly
horrified by what is going on in this
country
we have to start writing the ship and
hopefully i mean listen i i'm not going
to tell you it will happen
but hopefully the replacement of donald
trump with joe biden will be a start to
that
an inflection point of sorts one of our
sponsors today is magic spoon the reason
i'm such a fan of magic spoon is they
allow me to enjoy
the delicious breakfast cereals i loved
as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video